hey guys pete here today we're going to
be talking live about better call saul
we're going to discuss the first two
episodes of the sixth and final season
i guess these are the first two in the
first half because we have a halfway
point break in this season we're gonna
have two different installments
and hopefully you know me i'm pete
peppers this is my channel but i'm
joined today by my friend gill from the
one take channel and his brother adam
and they do a podcast together called
the salt saul cast is that correct
that's right
yeah and so you guys want to say hello
definitely yeah like you said i'm gil
this is adam
and uh yeah we uh he helps out on the
one take channel as well where we cover
better call saul a bunch of other shows
a bunch of movies but right now our main
focus is saul cast where talking about
better call saul every week
that's cool i see in the comments there
someone said you guys look like the
twins yeah
yeah be careful you don't want to mess
with us we're we're actually a lot
scarier than they are so watch out
yeah so you know we do this uh i've done
this in the past for the expanse um
we we did a podcast thing together gil
and i uh a few weeks ago and we wanted
to talk more and this is basically all
this is we're not gonna recap the whole
the whole episode we're just going to
talk about some things that we didn't
get to talk about in our coverage
things that came up after the fact maybe
i've been spending all my time reading
interviews and i listened to the insider
podcast so there's a lot of insights
there that i didn't have when i made my
video
and i think we should definitely dive
into this teaser like that is something
that i've been waiting to talk about
with other people
but i think before you know because
before we jump right into that i think
that maybe we should get into our
general feelings on
the episodes overall you just sort of
get that out of the way
because then if we run low on time or
something like that we'll at least have
been able to do that
and um i think maybe you guys can start
us off there if that's all right sure
yeah for me uh these two episodes kind
of did all the best things that better
call saul does which is it gave us
plenty of suspense especially on the
nacho story line it gave us plenty of
great character drama especially
watching kim
and seeing what she's really capable of
with the kettleman's
and then of course we also got some of
what i thought was the best humor on
this show but jimmy at the country club
running into kevin that was i was
laughing harder at that than i think
i've ever laughed at this show
so this show has always been a great
blending of multiple genres
and i think these first two episodes
kind of perfectly captured that
i i especially loved just
when we see uh saul goodman start to
strip naked and like my first thought is
okay maybe he's gonna hide in the shower
or something
but just he's such a quick thinker
thinking on his feet and anticipating
how other people react
uh where he just sits there and starts
toweling off he knows no one's gonna
look
uh yeah it's like the kind of humor we
love yeah the bro code exactly
yeah so i mean i i think you know there
was some table setting going on here i
mean it's inevitable you have to do that
um but i think that the potential of
what's to come it just gave it a
different feeling than previous episodes
and i do think they kind of moved things
they moved
into things like some of the stories
moved a lot faster
than what we've learned to expect from
them in the past
i think there's sort of an incremental
step going up from
the previous seasons i mean i think pace
what pacing wise you know season five
was a lot more intense
and i think they didn't really dial it
back as much this time as i mean if you
think about the season two opener or
season three i mean they they definitely
had a way of just
re-centering all everything at the
beginning of a season to in a way that
doesn't really happen here
and you know i like that there's trust
in the audience they they they don't
stop to explain everything they know
that we know these characters they know
we're familiar with this world and
um you know there was
there was you know there was a lot to to
kind of
put together on our own but i think they
did a pretty good job of leading us
there did you guys find that to be the
case
yeah i was gonna say in terms of
trusting the audience
uh
after these couple of episodes i saw
there's always debate after you watch an
episode of better call saul usually over
where is a character's head at that sort
of thing
but never have i seen so much debate
over
what did we actually witness what was
mike doing with the envelope uh what was
the whole plan around nacho
there were so many questions people who
was following jimmy and kim at the end
of the second episode i think a lot of
that on rewatch you know what was lalo
doing with those two farmers
on re-watch a lot of that makes complete
sense and you can easily connect the
dots but definitely a lot of trusting us
to just watch the characters and
understand what they're doing without a
lot of hand-holding
yeah i agree and and i mean i appreciate
that obviously um i
i like to be able to you know feel
like i figured something out when i'm
watching it put things together i mean
it's definitely a satisfying way to
experience it
and you know the
the teaser it just it brought up so many
questions that there was a kind of
afterglow when i you know when i got
done with that like it just sort of it
just sort of
hung over the whole experience of
watching it because it's like oh wow
we're going someplace we've never been
these are things that we've been
thinking about since you know breaking
bad what does saul goodman do at home
what does that look like and
you know this is i think
this is like
the this is a show that is famous for
cold opens right memorable cold opens
that that that linger throughout a
season and this is one of the best ones
that they ever had so i think we should
probably
get into that a little bit and there's a
couple of things uh one i saw this a
couple weeks early and
nobody else i knew had seen it so i was
just sort of sitting there with that
just wanting to talk to it talk about it
you know
um
it's just it i it's not something you
could have guessed would be the i mean
obviously you're thinking gene is going
to be the the opener but
you know the fact that that not only are
we going to see saul's house but it
looks like this
i mean did you guys
have any idea that this is might might
be the way that saul goodman lived
uh well first off i want to mention that
i can attest to pete just itching to
talk about this because in the weeks
leading up to the premiere he kept
messaging me to ask if i'd seen it yet
and i was so jealous that you already
had you're like do you care about
spoilers and i was like yes very much i
do um but one thing i love is that this
is the only show i've ever seen we're
simply showing us a scene that is in
color and not in black and white that
choice alone is like a jaw-dropping
decision and suddenly you know you're
seeing something really special
and one and they kind of juked you out
at the beginning because you think it's
in black and white at first you think
this is going to be your typical gene
opening but it wasn't right that
transition to color was like whoa okay
we're about to see something insane
and one thing i definitely felt in these
first couple of episodes is some
momentum towards a conclusion and i
think a big part of that is this opener
which
we've seen gene so we've seen kind of
the epilogue of the series but this is
the first time we've kind of seen
momentum towards the gene timeline and i
think that song choice the days of wine
and roses that nostalgic feeling of the
good times are rapidly coming to an end
or by the time we see that scene they've
already come to an end and that just
kind of hangs over everything
you know makes me think of that song
that's like uh those were the days my
friend i thought they'd never end
and and also
one thing that this show does a lot is
it just explores like the the physical
space that people
live in so like for example you often
get these shots of hector sitting there
alone in his wheelchair in this dank
kind of musty old nursing home sort of
setting
uh similarly
like we're we were we'd gotten pretty
used to seeing saul living and working
out of the back of a nail salon in what
essentially was a closet and now we cut
to see well he gradually ends up
advancing he's oh yeah there you go yeah
exactly that's the perfect contrast this
is this room with the golden toilet is
the size of the the office with the
little bed that he used to use
that's true i i hadn't made that
connection but yeah this is exactly
about how much space he had
total before yeah
and you know so the the starting set the
tone so well but then on top of that of
course you're watching closely to try
and get any clue you can into what was
happening with saul goodman's personal
life specifically
where is kim and then of course you end
with that slow zoom on the tequila
stopper which doesn't exactly answer the
question but it makes you think about it
in a new light
did jimmy hold on to that stopper
because it reminded him of kim or the
fact that it's there kim would never
leave without it does that mean she's
still around or does it mean she died or
does it mean she's lost a sentimental
attachment to it and she's left jimmy
behind so it doesn't answer the question
but it teases it in such a
impactful way the fact that they've been
able to attach so much significance to
that image of the tequila stopper is
pretty amazing
and uh
yeah so it makes for a great kind of
cliffhanger ending to that cold open
yeah and that that was the second point
i wanted to make with all these easter
eggs i mean
they're
there's so much in this like because
we're going in a prequel series and we
know that there's connections between
you know these these these episodes that
we saw in the other series years ago
that they're going to pop up from time
to time now we're at the point and
better call saul where we've had five
full seasons of that
and you know they they're so good at
not hitting you over the head with stuff
but just making it nostalgic in a way
that works and i mean this is like
over-the-top amount of easter eggs here
like you know
when i first saw this i thought okay so
the first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to make a bonus video about every
single thing that i see in this in this
thing you know i mean like you can't
help it that's like
the natural reaction to seeing all this
different stuff
and you know they've always done that we
talked about this in the past gil on on
several occasions about how they use
objects and how they
they use people in their own spaces to
convey what's happening you know where
there is no dialogue you know there's
nothing there's nobody explaining why
this person is doing what they're doing
or what they're doing so they they
explain it visually and they're so good
at that
and here you just have overload right
there's just a ton of things that you
remember
it's it's like i said the nostalgia is
there but it's not like oh hey look this
is a thing we're going to do just to
remind you how cool our show is and you
know you guys are all you know on in on
the joke or whatever
it feels like it's purposeful
and then you know i i i know you guys
have probably seen this too but peter
gould has said in several places
including the insider podcast that
not only are there are there a lot of
call backs but there's also a lot of
things that are going to be really
important in the season we hadn't seen
yet
and i noticed that right away that
connection of seeing the time machine
book that you see later in um
the upcoming episode and then that that
trains you to think okay now what what
do i need to be looking for
you know what am i going to see that's
going to tie us back that's going to be
a hint that we're going closer to saul
goodman
right after every episode now we're
gonna have to go back and re-watch that
teaser and see what dots we can connect
yeah i think um one thing i noticed on
re-watching this show recently is how
much time you spend alone with a
character and that's a tough thing to
pull off on tv in a book you have the
character narrating their thoughts but
on this show you just follow jimmy and
you'll often see him at the back of his
nail salon alone so they have to find
really clever ways to show you what's on
a character's mind so it might be like
that
was that oh yeah exactly yeah when he's
praying for
i need a phone call come on give me a
phone call exactly yeah i was just
thinking about him being in the store
throwing the ball against the wall yeah
exactly like the cc stress balls the cc
mobile stress which is like that's what
real life is like you know it's not all
full of things happening and so it's
the fact that they can show something
that we can all relate to in real life
but actually make it entertaining it's
sort of a miracle it really is and it's
you know in a in a lesser show you'll
have characters just constantly opening
up to each other and telling each other
what they're feeling what's on their
mind but in real life people often keep
that stuff to themselves so in these
first two episodes for example we don't
have jimmy telling kim you know hey i'm
pretty traumatized from our recent
experiences i'm a little off my game
instead you have them you know slip up
and say lalo to the d.a and then he goes
and sits in a room alone for a few
seconds and he's sitting there thinking
to himself i mean you have to kind of
fill in the blanks but to me he's
thinking man what did i just do like i
really need to get my head straight you
know i really can't think of a single
time those two characters disgust their
feelings to each other they they show
their feelings like like kim throwing
the bottles off the roof and then then
the next day sweeping up the broken
glass like that's a much more
entertaining and and i think
intelligent way to show someone's inner
state right show don't tell exactly yeah
absolutely and and i i don't want to i
don't want to go off too far on to a fee
season five but
yeah that's one of the things that
really stood out to me about their
relationship and where things might go
was that those two balcony scenes in
season five because
you could see that she was embracing
that she's throwing the bottle
there's that side of her maybe there's
more that we don't know about kind of
thing going on
but at the end she still cleans up even
though jimmy's like nah you know i don't
don't worry about it that's why we have
people that's why we pay rent or
whatever to have them take care of that
for us
so
yeah your your abs your spot on there
there's so many different examples of
stuff like that
so i guess um we'll probably mention it
some more we'll probably come back to
this teaser again but let's go through
the different characters i thought would
be the the easiest way to move through
this because there's a lot of plot and a
lot of intersection
so we might as well just
talk about the individual characters and
i guess we'll start out with lalo um
that makes that's sort of the the the
first thing that we see post
season five finale and if you guys want
to pick up with that that's why don't
you go ahead
sure um well i guess first off we can
kind of clear up the lalo body double uh
concept where basically he wants the
world to think he's dead especially he
wants gus to think he's dead so
apparently he's had a sort of plan b
ready where he has a couple of farmers
that live right off the compound one of
whom looks a lot like him one of whom
has had dental work done by wallace
dentist to ensure that if someone ever
checks this man's body they'll think oh
this is wallow so basically his first
visit after uh escaping the massacre is
these two farmers he has the guy shave
his beard leave his mustache and soul
patch brought the dead body back to the
compound burned it so nobody would know
that it's not lalo the twins find it and
now the world thinks he's dead um and i
saw somebody in the comments here asking
you know why was that body double okay
with being killed i think it's left a
little bit up to interpretation but my
impression is that he didn't know that
he was a body double he yeah he didn't
have the look of a man who was ready to
be executed right if he knew he was a
body double he probably wouldn't have
grown out that big bushy beard yeah
uh so lalo is charming and uh as uh
terrifying as ever i thought
yeah as far as that's concerned i think
that maybe he did understand that he was
a double but not that that meant he was
gonna die on that day yeah
they know what it is to show up in court
one day or something to protect yeah or
just you know just stand outside of a
warehouse somewhere you know where
someone could see him
there's a lot of different ways that he
could think that what he was doing was
just you know to pay back for what for
for the care that he had for his family
and yeah and one of the things that i
think is interesting about that is that
you kind of see that
lalo i mean
what i love about this is that they're
showing they're reminding us that the
super fun the super charismatic
character is absolutely dangerous and
he's brutal and he's gonna do what he
has to do to get
whatever he wants
right you know what i mean like he's
gonna sit there and smile and drink
their coffee and then he's gonna slit
their throats or whatever but
what i but what what was you know what i
thought was really
under the surface a little bit is that
he's not happy about doing this
you see that look on his face in the
mirror whenever you know the he says you
look very handsome or whatever he says
to the guy after he shaves and you see
the smile
disappear whenever he's not putting it
on for him anymore you see like his face
drop and i thought that was a really
nice touch because
he's brutal but he doesn't necessarily
feel good about this and that was one of
those things that we saw about him in
season five whenever he brought
everybody into the com when he brought
nacho into the compound and he's
introducing everyone
he you know he cared about his people he
cared about the normal people that were
there
and that's part of why this was such a
serious
bit of crossing the line by what gus did
yeah i think there are no characters on
this show that are just outright evil
even lalo has
some sort of uh code
you know i was i remember thinking last
season at one point we were having a
conversation where like this lalo guy is
so lovable is he really all that bad and
then he
reminisces with hector about where he
got that bell from and how they
basically burn look at that smile yeah
look at that guy how can you not love
him uh he burned a professor and his
wife alive at a hotel and then he went
back in to get the bell as a keepsake so
he can be evil but when they feel
disrespected or they feel wronged but i
agree with you when he killed his body
double the look on his face
when he's standing behind him to me was
a look that said
i am mentally preparing to murder
someone who has done nothing to deserve
it
he can do it yeah i don't think he felt
great about it well and there's there's
a difference so you didn't see that look
in the slightest when he killed what was
it fred whalen at the
the like money travel wire travel wire
place but this is different because this
is one of his people
yeah they even under they even
underlined the fact that he didn't care
about um
fred whenever they did the court scenes
where he you know he he saw his fake
family then he looked over and he saw
fred's royal family who's definitely
really upset that they lost their their
loved one and he doesn't look to have
any kind of um
connection to their pain or
and he doesn't even really acknowledge
it it's just sort of like oh well too
bad you know that guy was in the wrong
place at the wrong time
and that kind of stuff happens
so yeah
i i agree with um you know all of what
you're saying there i think that
to jump ahead um you know this idea that
that he needs proof that gus is working
against the cartel is is pretty
fascinating
it's kind of hard to figure out where he
goes from there initially when i watched
it i thought that he was going to go
after nacho but it doesn't seem like
that's the case what was your take on
that
yeah i initially
the the first time i watched it when you
see the car followed jimmy and kim at
the end i was like that's lalo and then
i realized that makes absolutely no
sense the whole point is he decided to
stay in mexico my next thought was
yeah i mean nacho would be the guy who
knows what really happened
but beyond that i'm not really sure what
kind of proof he could find what kind of
physical proof could he find that would
convince
uh donald audio or bulsa that gus was
behind this
i don't know pete did you have any
speculation on that
i do but i don't know if i should talk
about it now because um it's kind of
based on the teaser and some of the
stuff that peter gould said um yeah but
like i said my initial take was similar
to yours when i first saw the car i was
like wow nacho's already back in the u.s
this is crazy you know
i think we even talked about it gil in a
dm or something but um
uh yeah
that doesn't seem to be the case uh he
doesn't seem to be going back and he
doesn't he doesn't seem to be going
after nacho at all because that's the
thing right he's not trying to
he's not just trying to get this scheme
out he's trying to show the cartel
his bosses
that gus is ultimately working against
them and that he's a liability and even
though he makes a ton of money that they
are happy to take they need to get rid
of him and you know that's a whole
different situation when you really
think about it well and the ultimate
betrayal of gus against the cartel and
like the broader organization is the
fact that he's building this lab and
lalo was this close to figuring it out
he he knew about verner he was taking
like meticulous notes on the comings and
goings at the the laundry um he just
never fully put the pieces together
gotten it any evidence then again i
don't know what staying in mexico would
do to help him prove anything about the
lab so i so i still don't think that's
what the proof is related to
but we definitely haven't seen the last
of that threat either
yeah one other thing to think about is
that he's wanted in the united states as
jorge de guzman so that doesn't mean he
can't go anywhere else he just doesn't
really have a it's really not a great
idea for him to go to the us
he just needs to grow out that beard
yeah he needs to replace his body double
yeah
yeah it goes easy top go fools yeah
by the way i should clarify i see a few
people who are put off by my statement
that lalo salamanca is not evil
i guess i should clarify what i mean is
there's nobody on the show that is just
chaotic evil where they're just out to
do horrible things and have no
boundaries so i think it's clear that
lalo didn't want to kill this guy or at
least didn't feel great about it uh i
don't think there's anybody any there's
no serial killers on this show i guess
i'll say it that way gus is the closest
you'll get to that i think and
when it comes to lalo i would say he's
evil but he also has some qualities that
we like such as
loyalty to an extent at least in an
emotional sense and very directly toward
his immediate family you know i i
wouldn't i think he'd consider being
willing to die or put himself in extreme
danger for hector for example right
that's something he truly cares about
yeah yeah i think you know it's just
it's just a good complicated character
where he he's obviously
has
evil i mean think of i mean just think
of walter white or like you said gus
that they're they're bad people all the
way around you know what they do they're
they're
they have a negative effect on the
people around them on the you know on
the world as a whole
but
you kind of understand why they do what
they do what they're thinking
and they have those moments when you're
like okay
there are some there is some humanity in
there there are some things that i
recognize in there that are you know
just like other people i know
i will go on record agreeing with qwerty
manor it todd was pretty evil i thought
he might be the most evil one on the
show because he didn't even seem at
least gus says i know what i am i don't
even think todd understood how bad the
things he was doing was
and not in a way to defend him but to
say this is how messed up he was
yeah he he might i mean that's it's
saying something to say that anyone is
the worst but yeah you could you might
be on to something there he might be on
to
something so um anything else about lalo
you guys want to throw in there
he's just such a fun character yeah he
might be one of the best additions just
in terms of uh
like in some ways he's kind of the gus
of the series where there have been a
series of antagonists on both shows
but in both cases breaking bad and
better call saul you walk away where
when you think bad guy
for breaking bad you immediately think
of gus and then you think of a few other
people for me i better call saul if
someone asked me who's the bad guy on
that show like lalo would pop into my
head you know he's iconic he's one of
the iconic characters that have been
introduced on this show he's a bad guy
that you enjoy watching like similar to
gus i i'm curious about him i want to
keep watching whereas if i think about
the the nazis on breaking bad who also
made good villains i'm less curious to
say you know i want to learn more about
their lives or what they're up to
um and similarly with like tuko he was a
pretty good villain and i think
originally he was actually supposed to
be a much larger villain on the show
than he ended up being but i'm not it's
not like i'm craving to like see more of
him and learn more about him whereas
lalo
like every time i see him i'm like oh
man i want to see more of this guy
yeah and i think this is um oh sorry go
ahead
well no i was just gonna say that the
salamanca family they're also one note
you know what i mean like they just sort
of
they're like tuko is a hot head yeah
hector we hector was just you know
incapacitated then we found out he's
kind of uh uh
incompetent and just
you know
not really the greatest criminal that he
had a lot more mystique to him whenever
he was whenever he was incapacitated in
the original series right you know lalo
brought that in and and it and he filled
the hole that chuck left behind because
that was a big question you know that
that was so important in the first three
seasons and it still hangs over it but
that was the best
thing that was going on was was the the
this battle between chuck and and jimmy
and
whenever he's gone
gus had had emerged at that point but
you know we know what happens to him and
and then the added stuff with him i mean
i could take it or leave it it there's
you know
there's something to it but it doesn't
really
compare to what what we're watching on
the other side of the story so i think
that lalo really he was he was a
different kind of salamanca and he
really injected some life into that side
of the story
and i was just going to say if we want
to close out the conversation on lalo
you know of course he was invented kind
of incidentally in breaking bad because
of the one line you know did lalo send
you uh so the fact that saul says that
do you think that means well lala's got
to be alive
or the fact that gus tells hector with
you the salamanca family ends
essentially do we know if he's alive or
not or do you think it's just a total
open book at this point
i mean i think gus is the more reliable
source i mean his his whole life is
knowing and trying to punish the
salamanca family and you know everything
that's related to hector if he believes
he's dead there's got to be a good
reason that he believes that if it's not
true especially because we see gus
realize that lalo
survived right it would be kind of funny
from that to thinking he's dead now
later so right he faked his death
thought he was dead then figured out
he's alive and then once again thinks
he's dead it would be a little it would
be a little bit of a bizarre story
choice
oh and that brings up something i was
thinking about and uh i guess we won't
move on from lalo just yet um
it's interesting that that you know i
mentioned before how i thought it was a
good idea how they remind us how brutal
he can be how complicated he can be and
then
to think about it
i had a couple of people i had a couple
people bring this up in some of my
comments about it's wild that hector
knows that he tried to do this
i mean that's pretty much
he can put that together
lola told him that and you know what i
mean like
this is way before this relationship
comes to a close and so
throughout this period throughout this
story from this point on
hector knows that gus had had tried to
kill lalo at this point
so i thought that was interesting
yeah it's it's one of the things this
show has given us that i really enjoy
is the
the kind of different way to look at the
relationship between gus and the
salamancas we knew gus wanted revenge
but i love the fact that we find out
that that desire for revenge is almost
like pathological the whole story about
the kawate
so there's been a few examples of just
adding more nuance
to the whole revenge plot and the
relationship between gus fring and the
salamancas
yeah um
i guess we could just skip to gus right
now since we're we brought him up
because i think you know in the overall
i think
what i thought about gus before i saw
what they added and better call saul was
i thought that
he was just completely impenetrable you
know i mean he was just
down to everything was calculated it was
for a reason
you know he was some kind of mastermind
in a way that didn't involve being a
sociopath you know what i mean like i
felt like it was strictly business and
and it changed as time went on and um
that's what i thought was really
interesting about this gus part of the
story
in um
this first couple of episodes was seeing
him where things aren't working out you
know he's supposed to be the most
calculating man in the breaking bad
universe i think i've heard peter gould
say that he's the smartest man
and you know i would say what about
walter and that
but you know
plenty went wrong for both of these
characters either way but i mean
gus is
you know he's shook at this point and
that made it so that people were you
know a lot of people were asking about
why why he did what he did here it's
kind of hard to follow what you know
what he's trying to accomplish with
nacho and the safe and everything else
that was going on
right do we yeah just um but before we
get into the logistics of what happened
there i will say the moment of gus
knocking over that glass like you
alluded to seeing gus when things aren't
going exactly according to plan
um again just a simple
action to show us how nervous he is i
thought that was so effective
yeah it was super super
i mean you it just didn't feel right at
all you know what i mean you're like
wait you know that's gus how can he how
can that happen you know it felt it felt
like
we got to pay attention to this this is
important right like it was
uncomfortable to watch
it happen and to see him bend over to
clean it up and then the point where he
says you know continue right
yeah yeah
let's take a short
detour here i want to thank ian fieber
fibig
for the five dollars he said i totally
missed the body double thing thanks
thanks for sharing in the video yeah a
lot of people had that reaction
i kind of picked up on it in the trailer
whenever i did the um trailer breakdown
i thought that was the most likely thing
that was going on there so
i was looking for it going into it but
um i think it's supposed to be the kind
of thing that you put together
when you you know
it comes in waves you hear about the you
know you see what's happening then you
hear about the dental work then that
comes up again later it's sort of like
a three-step reveal kind of thing where
you know you get little pieces as the as
the um you know it as it develops and
goes on
so definitely thank you for that
five dollars
i think we have another one here too
richard o'brien thank you for the 4.99
he says gus will kill lalo before the
cartel finds out he survived the
hacienda massacre revealing the dramatic
irony of hector being the only one to
know
yeah that's what i was kind of touching
on that he's always going to know that
he's always got the back you know in the
back of his mind while he's sitting
there
at the old folks home do you guys have
anything you want to add to that
that would be dramatic and ironic if if
that if it played out that way um
i like that idea yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think that's totally plausible
yeah so thank you again for the super
chat
we have another one here we'll get to
before we jump back in um
a red wheelbarrow i guess that is a
mr robot maybe a mr robot reference um
i believe nacho was set up to die and
have the cartel barely missed taking him
alive mike was able to step in and try
to try his way once nacho managed to get
out alive
um
well yes he was he was certainly set up
to die he was supposed to die
specifically in a shootout that was the
whole thing with tyrus giving him that
that information to shoot if anyone
comes in the door
um mike was able to step in and try his
way once nacho managed to get out alive
i don't think we've seen that yet
well i think so i think this is a good
time to kind of similar to the lalo body
double thing i think this is another
part of the two episodes that required a
lot of dot connecting so i think what
red wheelbarrow is referring to here is
so first off let's talk about the
logistics of what was happening with the
safe and everything so basically nacho
is a big loose end because if the cartel
or the salamancas find him and get him
to talk now they find out that gus is
the one who tried to assassinate lalo so
for gus he wants nacho dead but he
doesn't want anyone to know that he's
the one who killed him and he's the one
trying to tie up loose ends so yeah
because because in that i just wanted to
add that you know
balsa balsa kind of threatens him a
little bit on his phone call whenever he
he's talking about it right so he's made
it a point that they want this guy alive
but at that point
he's already sort of
things are in motion so it's a little
bit
he he can't really just act decisively
right right and he tells us
if the salamancas themselves kill nacho
there's no question
to ask after that because clearly uh not
just the one who betrayed them so no
one's going to be like well he was a
double agent right
and um to your point pete
uh bulsa said to gus everyone is under
suspicion right now right as a warning
but you can also take it as a
gus we're not exactly uh we're not
accusing you of anything but we're also
not turning a blind eye
you know and from our perspective like
we we've seen so much of what gus is up
to
that it just feels so obvious that
like it's hard to believe that other
people
don't know for a fact that gus was
behind this right but we have to keep in
mind that we've seen so much more than
what anyone else does to everyone else
he's just the chicken man yeah
but how's gus going to get the
salamancas to kill nacho so that's where
he sends mike to nacho's house transfers
all the breaks into the safe transfers
all of its contents into a brand new
safe but slips an envelope in there
so that way when the salamakas and bolsa
come into the nachos house and they
break into the safe they find the
envelope and they think they've found
nacho's escape route they see the phone
number for the motel where he's staying
uh while he's waiting to be rescued
so and they're also transfer they're all
transfers from a peruvian bank and it's
you know everything in there points to
uh another country entirely
exactly so the salamancas and bolsa will
be going to find nacho meanwhile tyrus
has told nacho if anybody shows up shoot
at them so even if the salamancas are
trying to take him alive if nacho starts
shooting they're gonna take him out so
that's what we saw happen you know yeah
exactly
and so to read wheelbarrows point i
think mike accepted nacho's gonna die
when he transfers the contents of the
case you see that he puts nacho's fake
id into the new safe but he pockets
nacho's father so he's giving up on
nacho but he's still drawing a hard line
for nacho's father when nacho calls mike
he doesn't pick up the phone and then he
sits down and looks kind of disturbed so
the way i'm reading all of that is mike
has essentially given up nacho's in the
game it's up to him now to survive
but once nacho gets away like we see at
the end of episode 2
now mike has a chance to try and step in
and save nacho he tells gus give me four
guys i'm gonna go in and rescue him
before gus can give an answer of course
mike gets a call from nacho nacho says
he wants to talk to gus and that's where
we leave things so we don't know what's
going to happen but it does seem like
mike thinks that he does have to have an
opportunity but to potentially save
nacho at this point
oh go ahead go ahead go ahead adam well
i was just wondering what do you think
nacho
wants to
say do you think he has some kind of
bargaining chip up his sleeve or some
idea of something he can say to to prove
his value and that he he's still better
off alive than eliminated
i mean that's the thing that's really
kind of uh
bothering me about the um the nacho
thing is like i don't really understand
i mean i get that he's he's a he's
getting pulled back and forth between
these two different
factions that neither one of them have
anything good in mind for him at this
point
but i just don't really see
besides mike i really don't see how
anyone advocates for him or or where he
go like what can he he has no leverage
or anything you know what i mean
yeah i think you know one of the things
i love about nacho this season is that
we've just seen him bouncing back and
forth following orders from gus
and we haven't gotten to see him act
independently now we're finally getting
to see that him sneaking into the other
building
calling tyrus to get them to call the
guy watching him to prove that he's
working for gus was clever so we're
seeing how smart nacho is we already
knew that but now we're getting to see
him act independently we're really
getting to see what he's capable of
and i don't know what he's going to say
to gus but i'm hoping whatever it is
it's impressive and surprising and we
really get to see what nacho's made of
yeah just just real quick what i was
going to say about um about the mic
situation is the way i look at it mike
he he made his case
but he's able to accept it
based on his own code about you know
nacho made his choices
he's in the game
sometimes stuff happens you know what i
mean where i see him really drawing the
line is with is with papa varga
whenever he says if anybody's going to
go after him you're going to have to
come through me
like that is i feel like that is just
because
he's an innocent he's a civilian he has
nothing to do with anything and he
shouldn't have to be
shouldn't have to deal with the sins of
his father or his son you know in this
case right and there's a kind of a
connection between mike and his own son
in that situation
and you know i think that there is um i
think that's really where he might
actually
go against his boss because otherwise i
think mike is a you know he'll he'll say
what he thinks he'll do what
you know
what he wants to do but when it comes to
gus i mean he shot
he shot berner who he cared a lot more
about i think than nacho
and you know what i mean i think that he
understood that because you know what
berner went to went to he went to work
for a very crazy criminal and had this
stupid idea to run away and see his wife
after mike told him not to
to just give that idea up right so
i think that um you know that's really
where he might draw the line is with
nacho's father but he'll if if we have
to see
if he has to see him be a sacrifice he
has to see nacho be a sacrifice and he
could live with that well the thing i
love about mike's character is he has a
very consistent and understandable sense
of justice even if it's not the kind of
justice ordinary people think about it's
still consistent
and he makes a clear divide between the
criminal and the non-criminal world and
i can only imagine that that feeling of
justice and the pursuit of justice is
probably what drew him to law
enforcement in the first place and it
turned out to be just as crooked as the
world he entered afterward and
ironically
um where right now we essentially see
mike letting go and saying maybe nacho's
going to die here because he's in the
game
i was trying to trace back when is the
first time we actually hear mike use
that phrase in the game and it's shortly
after he hears it from nacho back in
season two when mike robs the
truck and leaves the driver tied up on
the side of the road nacho says to mike
anybody in the game would have capped
the guy without a second thought
somebody left him alive so i knew it had
to be you
and then a few episodes later when gus
is asking mike why he wants to kill
hector and mike essentially says hector
killed that good samaritan he wasn't in
the game so it's not said explicitly but
it seems to me he picked up that phrase
from nacho that's where he kind of
learned this moral code of you know what
people in the game sometimes do have to
die
and now nacho is kind of on the other
side of that from mike he's he's sort of
the victim now
yeah and just just
a little off topic it's also funny that
whenever we were re-watching we were
talking about how nacho
how that was his kind of his role with
jimmy in the first season where jimmy
didn't see
his situation for what it actually was
but you know nachos said hey give me a
call when you realize you're in this you
know when you're in the game or whatever
which is is a nice recurring occurring
deal there with that that idea
real quick tim h thank you for the 499.
he says we never actually saw nacho
escape chances he's now under lalo's
thumb
uh like i said earlier i don't think
lalo is
immediately concerned about him i think
that the cousins are going after for
going after nacho um
you're right about the fact that we
didn't see him escape
we do hear on the phone that
they found nacho's truck but they didn't
find him so he's he's out there in the
countryside somewhere
yeah and i think uh
i can't imagine nacho truly being under
anyone's thumb at this point he's been
backstabbed so many times so even if
somehow he ends up interacting with lalo
and going along with him i have to
imagine that nacho will always be
scheming in the background and i think
he's trying to no longer be the victim
he needs to start striking back
uh and if he goes back into that kind of
victim role where he's just gone to his
father's head so he has to do whatever
gus says or whatever lalo says it'll
kind of be like treading over familiar
ground so i think from even just from a
storytelling perspective we have to see
nacho fighting back and doing something
clever to just no longer be
i'm very curious to see how his plot
goes because i can't imagine a way that
he can go on the offensive and not just
assume that that's going to kill his
father which which i think he he would
not accept
any course of action that he knows would
cause his father to get killed
it does make it super complicated for
him and
his only other thing is
death by torture
those are his two options yes right yeah
get my dad killed or get myself killed
slowly by you know whatever
i mean
he knows i'm sure he understands who the
cousins are who they are as people
um i think the reputation
kind of you know precedes them so
that's all real stuff that he's doing
and you know his
his whole situation it was a little bit
it wasn't like it wasn't like grab you
you know it wasn't the most exciting
stuff but
it really it really worked well to
because you know i kept thinking about
this like
there's nothing there there's no
distraction all you're doing is you're
just stuck in this room waiting and all
you're thinking about are these people
coming from you and the fact that you
got double crossed and the fact that
there's nowhere you can go
and it's just so intense and and the
only thing he can really do is just sit
there and put it together and solve the
puzzle on this like super basic level
like what's going on outside my window
what's going on what could possibly what
do i need to be watching out for what
can i do
if this happens you know it's it's super
intense you know like i said it's not
like
thrilling until the actual
you know gun fight breaks out or
whatever but when you think back on it
can you imagine being there sitting in
that room
no
no yeah i don't i can't i could sit in a
room for a while if i have my laptop get
some writing done that sort of thing but
if i'm constantly wondering if someone's
coming to shoot me that would probably
be a mild distraction
um yeah but it was tense i mean it was
sort of the ticking time bomb where
every time we cut to nacho a as always
he's looking nervous as ever
so you just feel that you can't not look
at him or you can't look at him and just
not also feel somewhat nervous but every
time
no air conditioner so he's sweating his
ass off the whole time right
so every time someone comes to the door
you just don't know what's going to
happen
uh it's a very tense scene how is he
even supposed to trust the food that's
being put out there right
yeah it's all it's all a nightmare it's
it's not it's a living nightmare after
he ran miles to get there you know what
i mean through the dark
yeah because we know the character and
we you know we're just curious what
happens next i think you can kind of
overlook that a little bit but it's it's
an insane situation that he finds
himself in
so i i guess um we kind of touched on
gus and mike is there anything with
those two that you want to you want to
bring up before we move on and talk
about the the our favorite couple here
i just want to add with mike that when
he stood up to gus at the end of episode
two drawing that hard line to protect
nacho's father
i just that was such a gratifying moment
i feel like on this show with such
when we're always in the kind of moral
gray area you can never just outright
root for someone when we're watching
jimmy and kim go after howard it's fun
to watch how that plan unfolds but
constantly in the back your mind you're
a little bit worried about howard and
where they're going to go with that
but here this is one of the rare
occasions where we can all look at this
and say nacho's father does not deserve
to die or get pulled into this in any
way shape or form so to see mike stand
up to gus with a gun in his face and
just stone face tell them this is not
going to happen the way you think it was
a badass moment and it just felt so
gratifying to see him draw that hard
line and and like you said stand up for
papa varga
and hi and is how crazy is it that we
absolutely know that neither one of
these characters anything's going to
happen to either of them at this point
in the story you know what i mean like
it's amazing how that can how like
how many things they have to do right in
a scene to make it feel that intense
even though we know that
what's going to happen later with these
characters you know well and it's it's
not like it's a fake tension or they're
trying to fool us into thinking that oh
what if mike dies here because everyone
knows he's not and you can even see on
his face does that look like the face of
a man who's who's really that afraid
like i think
he's he's just doing what feels right
and he's standing up he's already said
whether he lives or he dies doesn't
really make a difference to him
um and like
you know down to the core like the actor
behind him i think really feels that and
is conveying it perfectly
yeah it's it's um you know sometimes the
mic story can can feel a little
disconnected and
sometimes it it really
you know it really just brings a kind of
humanity that we don't always get in
other characters and i think that's this
is kind of the latter
where he's caught up i mean he's
obviously an operator he's obviously
very good at what he does he he we know
he goes along with it but you know
there's a there's that that one
thing that still kind of makes him a
little different than everyone else in
his world
so anything else on mike or gus
i think that's it for me yep
all right so obviously i just kind of
want to finish up with kim because she's
the most fascinating so let's go to
jimmy first and
you know um
i listened
you know i listened to the to to the i
think it was in the in the insider
podcast and they said that this episode
was kind of about jimmy getting his mojo
back or coming back and i i don't think
i actually put that together in that in
that way when i was watching it live
but i mean i was very conscious of how
broken he is he's just in pieces
from the end of season five in the
beginning and
i gotta say i think you already touched
on this um
adam that you know uh
seeing him come back to life in the
country club that was that was just
something that man it was just i don't
know like i said i watched this
and you know i didn't really have much i
i guess
you know i kind of figured that
i i've kind of had a little bit of
suspicion about this idea of scamming
howard because
they're the most likely people to do it
jimmy is you know i mean like i can't
see how howard doesn't see this coming
and it's coming from them
but um
i'm i'm i'm able to to suspend that
disbelief when it comes to how much fun
it was watching bob and kirk slip into
this
in this actual scene here it's like
watching a star athlete like improvise
on the field and
and do something really
just dazzling right in terms of talking
your way out of a tough situation he's
an olympic athlete yeah so let me ask
you did you guys think that this was
staged like he was planning on seeing
seeing kevin wachtel or this is a
complete audible because i i thought it
was a complete audible i agree with that
yeah that's how i saw it and i think it
could be a big problem because
they don't want howard or anyone to know
that jimmy was there
and if kevin talks to howard at all i
feel like that's probably going to come
up and jimmy made a big scene it wasn't
even just kevin but so many people saw
him
yeah it was actually really ill-advised
and that's why i was saying i'm i'm
willing to suspend a little bit of
disbelief and we don't know how they're
going to end up writing it in in the end
but
you know like these people talk to each
other they're an elite
circle of people that's the whole point
of the country club right is that you go
there and and you're only around people
that that are also paying to be there
and you know it kind of keeps everyone
else out so there's that whole uh
dynamic and
yeah this is something that people would
talk about i mean he's shouting at the
top of his lungs talking about man it's
all it's all mayonnaise or whatever
wall-to-wall mayonnaise i think is what
it was wasn't it that's right yeah
um saul goodman already also it's not
like he just has a kind of a crappy
reputation with
howard now it's it's like he worked for
cliff maine um and made an ass of
himself there too so so even though
maine is a little perturbed by what he's
seeing with howard and
and he's kind of trying to connect these
dots and he's wondering oh i don't know
maybe howard is on the devil's dandruff
as soon as he learns that saul was there
that day it's
i mean that's gonna
cause a big problem even before learning
that saul was there that day i mean
last season jimmy threw bowling balls at
his car yeah
had prostitutes interrupt alliance well
that's the other thing cliff man was
there for that and it's all it could all
add up okay so either this person i
thought i knew really well turns out to
be some kind of
um
person with an addiction who's seeing a
bunch of prostitutes or
saul goodman is acting like the person i
know he is well cliff i think has less
experience with jimmy so i don't
necessarily i could see him falling for
this but i could also just as easily see
howard suspecting jimmy pretty quickly
he planted these drugs here i feel like
the first person he'd suspect is jimmy
and and you know this is this is
something the show's good at you know
like one of the things i loved about
re-watching season two was seeing how
jimmy underestimated cliff maine in that
whole situation you know like he he's
thinking i'm doing all this crazy stuff
he's going to fire me
what what cliffs didn't think like i
this guy's such a piece of you know
piece of work that i got rid of him he's
like this guy is trying to get fired so
i might as well just give him what he
wants because it's easier for me than
having to deal with this all the time
you know what i mean yeah yeah they
don't make people stupid just to make
them stupid you know so it you know i've
been saying this since i watched the
very first
trailer that
i i feel like they have to be
anticipating
how howard's gonna respond and playing
you know steps ahead like they know he's
going to to get come on to them and then
that's all part of their plan because i
don't see how they really make this work
otherwise like
kimmy or kim and jimmy are too smart and
howard's too smart so they can't just
say
oh we thought it'd be a great idea to
continue these pranks that are ongoing
that howard i mean howard just told her
about this like two days ago in the
show's timeline
about jimmy throwing the bowling balls
and sending the prostitutes you know
what i mean right so
it'll be interesting to see how that
moves forward from there yeah i i have a
suspicion that there's more to this plan
than we realize it's not going to be as
simple as we set up howard to look like
a drug addict and uh and that's that's
pretty much it because it was very
blatant that when jimmy and kim were
discussing the plan we didn't get to
hear it yeah so i think there's going to
be i mean it could be something like
howard starts accusing jimmy of trying
to manipulate events to ruin his life
well you know that was like one of the
things that was chuck's downfall was his
need to try to clear his name into and
to accuse saul of the things he actually
was doing um and so if they can kind of
goad uh howard into retaliation or at
least public publicly going after him or
accusing him it could come back to bite
him right if there are enough events
manipulated like putting baby powder in
his locker
to anybody who doesn't know jimmy and
what he's capable of howard would sound
insane with his accusations which that's
exactly what i was thinking about is
chuck because that's what happened to
him when he was in front of the board
hearing and he started saying the thing
with the billboard jimmy faked that and
he was pulling the strings here he's
behind everything it makes him look
insane even though everything he said is
true yeah so there could be something
similar happening with hamlin here
yeah i mean that was my that was my take
from from the start was that
you know a lot of if you look back at a
lot of the scams that he ran with um
marco
a lot of them are setups where the mark
thinks that they're driving
the action you know they're basically
playing right into their hands but they
think that they're getting over on
jimmy and marco only for the roles to be
reversed and you know it plays out that
way and i and i think that that's what's
going on with with kim and jimmy and
would be pretty surprised i mean i'm
pretty married to the idea at this point
you know what i mean but
we'll see how they do that another thing
that i liked here um
you know whenever
like i said jimmy's kind of in pieces at
the beginning he's definitely not
100 on board with what's going on with
with uh her ideas about going after
howard
and i like the way that you saw that
he can't really like
he can't really go against her either
like he's he's definitely got some
turmoil there of like
if you think about it
and this may this may turn out to be
really devastating and tragic later but
you know he's kind of at the place that
he would always have wanted to be right
he's got the he's got the wife he's got
the woman at his side
she's finally you know they had some
they had some distance in between them
at times she's finally on board she's
finally fired up about doing things that
he's really good about doing and
it's not necessarily what you know it's
sort of one of those situations careful
what you wish for what do you guys think
about that
i agree with that i think the tables are
starting to turn and
whereas before it was saul who was
leading the way with all these schemes
and
all this gray area activity
um
kim's a quick learner and she can be
very devious and i think she's starting
to get ahead of him
yeah i think uh i mean it says it all
when jimmy gets back in the car after
kim faces down the kettleman's and he
says to himself wolves and sheep
and that's of course a call back to the
flashback we saw either in season one or
two i can't remember where jimmy
basically is season two okay i think
that's right where jimmy is at his
father's corner store he watches his
father gets scammed over and over again
and one of the grifters turns to jimmy
and says well there are wolves and sheep
in this world figure out which one
you're going to be and so i think in
this moment jimmy thought he was on his
way to becoming a wolf
but now he sees that kim has
she's a wolf she makes him look like uh
what did you say a little a little puppy
yeah something like that a labradoodle
yeah i i think it's pretty fascinating
stuff and we'll we'll come back to her
and i want to come back i want to circle
around back to that wolves and sheep
ideas so definitely keep that in mind
because
you know there's a lot of like big
picture questions that that that revolve
around that and i was really
really
like whoa whenever he said that because
you know i'm not even sure
what we're supposed to think about that
but i don't want to get too derailed at
this point because you mentioned the
kettlemans
and
man was that not like this is actually
something that got spoiled for me
because when i got the email i saw the
do not do not um
you know the do not disclose list and it
said don't mention the kettleman's and i
said
no
now i know the kettlemans are going to
be but i could not have even even
knowing it going into it man there was
that not the like
perfect return character situation here
i mean i never get tired of betsy's
inability
to play the victim
to really believe it to sell it yeah
and just be able to completely overlook
it i mean they are criminals they're
absolutely criminals they're dirty they
craig went to jail and got back out and
they went straight back to the grind of
ripping off vulnerable people you know
and meanwhile craig craig is so friendly
and nice and likable and meek yeah when
he just walks all over him i cracked up
at the mazel tov line when he
congratulates them for getting married
yeah and then laughed even more when he
tells kim oh press nine to dial out yeah
well she's in the process
they do such a good job on this show
of
they know they need characters to
fulfill a certain role and then they
look at their array of existing
characters and if they have an existing
character that organically makes sense
there and can do what they need them to
do they'll bring them in and i think
because they use that method these
reappearances that we're so happy to see
just as fans they never feel like fan
service they always feel thematically
appropriate and just they don't feel
like they break the reality of the show
it feels organic
yeah i mean it as a as an idea it sounds
like why would these people fit back in
but they made it work you know i mean
they they put it together in a way
where you know it's believable to me
that kim might have found out about them
she might have looked into what they
were up to i mean they they had
she ended up in dock review in the
basement because of them by because they
wouldn't listen to her and they laughed
you know
so there are definitely people that she
would remember and if craig got out of
jail then you know it's very possible
that she might you know kind of loosely
keep an eye on what they were up to and
what they were doing
and yeah you guys were saying like
obviously betsy kind of runs the show
but it only works as good as it does
because craig the character who plays
him i mean this guy is a master brow
furrow or like his the way that he can
he can just switch like he he's like
he's standing there he's waiting he he's
a hundred percent like
excited to see jimmy yeah he's also he's
also he's also trained to know that he
follows what his wife
you know he he he looks to her for the
clues of what he's going to do you know
that that's i mean obviously we don't
see them behind closed doors but we can
imagine
what that is like you know what i mean
like he you know he definitely gets led
around by whatever she wants to have
happen so
yeah the actor really nails the the
facial expressions and the way that he
shifts
from being like completely happy to
completely concerned
and
just doesn't look like he has a feeling
of his own you know i mean yeah he just
he just repurposes anything at a drop of
a hat
you know the show does a great job
squeezing comedic relief out of people
who are
uh kind of caught in between identities
so especially when it comes to these
people who are criminals but they're not
hardened criminals they're kind of soft
criminals they're like white-collar sort
of criminals and and these the
kettleman's kind of remind me of the guy
who is selling pharmaceutical drugs
daniel
yeah and he was like my cards you know
and he wanted to call the police because
the things he paid for was stolen money
were stolen from him
yeah
yeah it is i mean that that's what makes
them as as good as they are too that's
that's a big part of it is how
they really don't see what they're doing
is bad
you know they're not bad like how
jimmy's bad or they're not bad how
nacho's bad or gus or lalo or anybody
else they're just you know they just
deserve a little bit more and they
figured out a way to get it and
nobody should bother them for for you
know wanting to send their kids to
private school
yeah i think they do self-justify in a
little bit of the same way that jimmy
does
if you remember the kettleman's back in
season one betsy kept saying craig
earned that money he worked so hard and
essentially just didn't get what he
deserved
it's almost like the world was already
screwing us over so this is just kind of
balancing the scales and i think it's
not exactly the same as the way jimmy
sees the world but if you do think of
the world as wolves and sheep the basic
idea is that if you don't take advantage
of other people then they're going to be
taking advantage of you
so it's kind of like i'm not doing
anything wrong i just i have to do this
because that's the world we live in
yeah and in that and it's funny because
they're you know they're they're
suburban they're
white bread and you know what i mean
it's funny to think
and i mean i think that that is you know
that there's a lot of of uh
there's a lot of that that happens
across the board you know people like
you kind of think about like lawyers as
a profession you know i mean not not all
lawyers are bad but
many lawyers do things that you know
they would
i mean they're i mean i don't want to
make anybody
feel bad but you know what i'm saying
like you know
we all we're all the hero of our own
story right and um
some of us like to bend the rules and
don't think that it is as bad as what
other people are doing
it's just a part of you know how people
operate well you feel like your reasons
for it are are valid compared to right
compared to other people
and the best way to make yourself feel
bad about or feel good about that is to
look at how bad other people are you
know
how bad their reasons are you don't have
to look at your own
so that's why you know saul is the kind
of lawyer that guilty people hire you
know
yeah
which is exactly them
that's right
but they don't want to hire them because
you know it doesn't fit their personal
image
so i i don't know if you have anything
but uh
you can bring it up when we get into kim
because like i said i think you know
this is the most fascinating thing
that's happening right now
one thing from the opener i i took away
from it was that she is nowhere near
that that saul goodman mansion at that
point
um
she definitely is not
in jimmy's life behind behind the scenes
whenever he goes home at night from from
being walter white's lawyer are you guys
in agreement with that so so i initially
was and then
i thought about it some more on my
second watch through of these episodes
and then i wasn't so sure
because we see that kim is the one who
questions the car that jimmy is driving
oh saul goodman drives a brown forward
doesn't shouldn't he drive something
flashier and then she's also the one who
says we also need to find saul goodman a
nicer office
so i could see her pushing for
we need to craft the image of saul
goodman now yeah don't forget she's also
the one who stands up to lalo when he
walks into their home
um and that you know that's from last
season but but they're showing like she
she's got some
more confidence than saul seems to have
lately
and kind of a really
good sharp head on her shoulders for
this stuff exactly so those were kind of
the two things that made me think there
is a chance that she's around one yes
that was over the top decadence but
maybe she would have pushed for that to
help craft the saul goodman image now
i'm not so sure because that is his
private residence and ideally you
wouldn't be bringing cartel leaders or
criminals that you're representing to
your house
but you may have company over at some
point and you want to maintain that salt
goodman image and then to your point
we see that kim is the one
that
knows when to pull out the stick when
the carrot's not going to work and that
seems like something that saul goodman
would know how to do so maybe jimmy's
just learning it from her and then he
carries it along as he becomes saul
goodman
or maybe she's continuing to push him
she doesn't get her hands dirty but she
will in the background advise saul
goodman so i i'm not certain about that
but i did consider it as a possibility
the second time i watched these episodes
i'll say this gun to my head
i would say she's not there anymore but
we have slightly i think slightly more
reason to believe maybe she is
than we did before or we at least have
uh
that gap just hasn't been filled in at
all before and now there's a few more
dots to interpret
i think she's i think she's pushing for
it i mean i i think that part is clear
but i i don't think that um
i don't think that that really backs up
the idea that she would still be there
or that she would actually um you know
join in that
you know what i mean like
i think that
that seems more like a reaction to the
way things went than
than the natural conclusion of of this
conversation that they're having at the
el camino diner
and you know what i mean like uh
i mean there's there doesn't really seem
to be a lot of her there
um there seems to be
you know stuff that he kept that was
important to him and
not so much the other way around and um
i would be really surprised
if that was if that's what happened like
that's their their house that they share
i mean i'm not saying that it's pos it's
not possible that they didn't at one
time
but to me
i i don't see i see i see her i see her
memory there i see the influence of the
of whatever happened to them there but
not
not her
not her person right
yeah we see a lot of uh mementos from uh
from jimmy's life you know we see like
the hat he wore in the saul goodman
commercial where he's standing in front
of the satellites the cc mobile stress
balls we don't see you know there's a
letter that kim received from one of her
clients
that she always looks at when she wants
to think about the the real work she
wants to do representing people who need
justice and can't afford it we don't see
anything like that really the only thing
we see that we know was important to her
was the stopper which yeah could have
just been jimmy holding on to holding on
to it for the memory of kim
um yeah
there is the question of the thong
hanging from the that's true that's the
that's the one thing
again you know what i mean like they
they went to the they went to the point
of showing that he has viagra there and
it's true yeah minoxidil or whatever
it's called the the the hair hair
regrowth um
stuff like
yeah it just seemed like it's more of a
situation where they're showing that
that this guy
you know is trying to be
something
he's trying to be something that isn't
you know
all that recognizable from what we've
been seeing
as jimmy mcgill
mm-hmm yeah
or he's trying to he's he's covering up
for some things that have that have left
right if he lost him and now he's trying
to fill that void in his life with just
yeah that's that would be my take
one of my favorite uh
uh fan theories which which is certainly
you know it's sort of a joke meme fan
theory is that kim becomes wendy yeah
and breaking bad
yeah i i i have
laughed at i have laughed at that one
many times too i would be i would be
actually i would be just disappointed if
they did go that way but
yeah
it is funny it is a funny idea
so one of the things that i thought
about you know i think that we saw i
think that we saw that kim is still
this idea of her being a force of force
for good you know to be able to um help
people to do pro bono all the time you
know we see her beaming in the beginning
whenever she's talking to to jimmy about
that that part is all very real you know
like that's that's really what's driving
her decisions here like she has a reason
that she thinks is a good one
and this other stuff that's going to
have to happen now
it makes sense inside her you know
inside because it it's a means to the
end does that make sense
yeah yeah absolutely i mean she she
basically her plan with the money that
they get from the sandpiper settlement
is to open up a great practice where
they can give the best representation to
people who typically couldn't afford it
i mean it's it's the robin hood idea
and i do think she believes that and i
do think there is definitely good in her
heart and she she absolutely means it i
mean you see how much pleasure she gets
from what jimmy thinks sounds like a
horrible day but it was the best
professional day of her life and she had
to add the word professional
um so that was really that may have been
the best day of her life so i genuinely
believe all of that
um but it's trying to have your cake and
eat it too i mean it's what mike accuses
gus of
in dedicado on max trying to do some
good to balance the scales for all the
bad you do can you do that kim's trying
to
um but what's gonna happen when she i
mean if howard fights back and pushes
her into a corner
uh what's gonna happen
yeah i mean i i think that it was pretty
apparent that she had this scammy side
that that that was under the surface you
know we saw that come out the question
then is is this something that she's
always had or
i mean in the breaking bad universe you
know the the the vince gilligan universe
you kind of think that
that's probably the case right if we see
this coming out right now that she's
really into the you know she's really
exhilarated by scamming people
that she you know that that's really
driving her and getting her caught up
then that's probably some there's that's
probably always been there
and and it's just coming out right
yeah i think so i think there's a
complicated i don't know that it always
necessarily would have manifested as she
likes to scan people
but it it definitely comes from
something that's been inside her for a
long time
yeah i guess that's what i guess that's
sort of what i'm saying is you know do
you think that
scamming has been a part of her life
before
we got to this point and she sort of
reversed roles and became straight you
know
and now we see her backsliding do you
think that's the case or do you think
this is just opening up a part of her
that that wasn't there or you know
that she wasn't aware of
i think she's had sort of a dark
quasi-self-destructive
streak
um
probably forever that has just gradually
evolved and taken shape into
scamming and and it would have probably
turned into something else had she not
met jimmy um and like one thing i think
about is
is like
early scenes of kim when we see
flashbacks of her and when she was still
a law student um and the scenes were
where she and jimmy are just kind of in
the parking garage smoking cigarettes
for example like that's something they
do in the shadows it's not something
they really want associated with their
professional identity and it's sort of a
miniature version of where her character
goes
yeah
yeah and i agree with all that yeah
i saw a really interesting interview in
the um la times and they talked to both
peter gould and ray seahorn and they
were talking about this last moment of
of the um
whenever she looked upset because jimmy
gave um the kettleman's the money and i
had some people
my thought was is that that was you know
that had put her off that she wasn't you
know she didn't feel good about that
that there was something about that that
was you know troubling to her and i had
some people push back in the comments
about that that they thought that wasn't
the case um what was your take on that
did you did you guys pick up on that
i saw it more as she was almost amused
because i think the reason she decided
to go to the meeting is because she asks
jimmy you're going to use the stick
right and he says no he's going to offer
that money use the carrot and that's
what she said that's true that's
definitely true why she of the reason
why she went right so i think she has
this idea that jimmy is a little bit of
a softie and can't go as hard at these
people as he needs to
so when he proves that to be the case by
giving them the money she's kind of
laughing at him saying i i knew you
didn't have it
yeah i called it that's essentially how
i saw it
um i
i know she has good reason to hate the
kettleman's and be disgusted with them
i think it was very purposeful that when
they were walking in she sees an elderly
woman walking out somebody very
vulnerable and she knows that this
person is getting taken advantage of the
exact kind of person that she would want
to represent in court the kettleman's
are taking advantage of her
but i also think yeah yeah go ahead go
ahead
go ahead and i'm just going to say i
think the overriding emotion in that
moment when jimmy came out was amusement
uh i don't think the money will do that
much to kind of
uh save the kettlemans from the tough
situation they've put them in
anyway so i don't think she sees it i
don't think she looks at it with a lot
of disgust it was more just amusement in
that moment
right and that was the point that people
had had brought up and i started to
second-guess myself and then i saw this
interview in the la times yesterday and
race ray seahorn said when she was asked
about it she said kim has gotten into
the dangerous business of thinking that
she's the arbiter of what people deserve
at this point
she doesn't like that jimmy's being soft
with the kettleman's
it's a very dark moment for her
so that's something to think about she
thinks they don't deserve
to be treated with the carrot
right right
and so so you know it that does that
does bother her that jimmy does this so
um
it's uh i i think this is a fascinating
idea this idea of her being the arbiter
of what people deserve and
you know there's a
she went on to say
that
you know
when you get into when you cross that
line of where you think you're the
person who can can make those decisions
things can get a little bit off the
rails right
yeah it's like uh
i mean i mean
a
you may be right or wrong when you're
deciding somebody does or doesn't
deserve something
um but b there could be real
consequences to that like i think we're
going to see with howard because if you
just if you decide to if you decide
someone does or doesn't deserve
something and then try to act on that
you're not always going to be able to
get away with it
yeah and you're giving yourself
permission to you know to
to you know make decisions for people
right to make you know put people in
situations where they're going to
experience consequences
and you know nobody
really
you know that's not something that
individual people are you know
i mean that's what the law is for right
right yeah that's what i'm saying it's
not something that people are
are are good at being unbiased and you
know fair and and and not getting their
own you know personality mixed up in the
in the situation
i think let's let's look at these uh
we had a couple of um
a couple of super chats andrew loden
thank you for the five dollars he said
what if kim is the opposite of jimmy
saul outside home
she's pure
jimmy behind the scenes at home she is
flashy soul and pushes him on
what do you guys might be more i mean i
i think i kind of already touched on
what i thought there what do you guys
think about that yeah well i think we
essentially talked about this earlier
where i didn't think this was a
possibility until i sort of rewatched
the episodes and thought about it seeing
kim push for jimmy to get a flashier car
get the saw goodman office
um i i still wouldn't bet my money on
this you know i agree with you like at
the end of the day i would still bet on
kim not being there
but i think it's a possibility i also
don't think kim herself is flashy she's
sort of saying
saul has started to adopt this flashy
persona you know he's doing the finger
guns and he wears these gaudy suits and
everything so she's helping flesh out
the character
but it's not like her own person i don't
think the gold toilet is actually your
own personal taste
yeah and i i i think that you know that
that kind of brings up something that i
had mentioned in my video i think that
this is uh you start to look like she
might be using jimmy as a tool
not as her partner
not as someone that she is you know
happily married with or whatever you
know what i mean like
he
he he can inhabit this space this
character a lot easier than she can i
know we're seeing a little bit of a
different look in the way that she's
dressing and stuff like that but
she can't really be saul goodman she
can't really be what they need in that
regard you know that's something that
that's right up jimmy's alley and that
kind of gives me a little bit of concern
that she's just
using him for his for her her purposes
which you know i just kind of don't want
to believe is is
the big thing that's happening here
and uh we have seen jimmy feel that way
before he's accused her of basically you
want to come to me when you are ready to
roll around in the mud yeah right yeah
and then she doesn't think that she
respects him that's that's for sure
absolutely and i think
the first time we see them in episode
one after they leave the house she
throws away the second best lawyer mug
and that's where i the way i read that
between her and jimmy is that maybe
she's letting go of some of the
sentimentality between them that mug was
important to jimmy when he and mike were
pushing his car into the ravine he
stopped it ran back and grabbed that mug
because it was important to him and she
throws it out uh does that mean that
maybe some of the romance is going away
and this marriage for her truly is just
a professional thing and she is just
using him as a tool
i think that's how jimmy read her
throwing that mug away anyway so um
we'll wait and see where her head's at
but at a minimum i think that's how
jimmy read it
yeah and there's a there's another one
here from dubs house uh thank you for
the five dollars
he said you all missed the kim prison
foreshadowing in the restaurant that's
something i did see i didn't mention it
but you know this this is that scene
where um
like you brought up earlier where we
don't know what they're saying they
continue to plan but we get the outside
look
you know we're looking on the you know
we're looking at things through the
window and and there's kind of like bars
on the window there
yeah and i don't i wouldn't say it's it
means she's going to go to prison but
it's you know they're playing a
dangerous game they're they're flirting
with law breaking and they like we're
being reminded there are potentially
serious consequences for kim
yeah and i think there was another shot
like this in in season four where she
was looking through uh
the little
things that they made for mesa verde the
little uh model model banks or whatever
that people pointed out at that time
looked like
she was behind bars
which there i could definitely see
thematically what they would be trying
to say visually because i think she felt
a little
um trapped there when she was looking at
all of the model banks that they were
putting up she had this feeling of this
is not what i wanted to do with my life
and uh i think she wanted to get out of
there and she wanted to do the pd work
so at least that wasn't necessarily
foreshadowing that she was going to
prison but she was in sort of a prison
of her own making at the time
yeah
and and then it could also work both
ways though couldn't it
you know and i think that that's the
biggest thing that i that i'm thinking
about
with kim right now is this has been a
long road and we there's so much that we
don't know about her still
and i just wonder how many twists and
turns that are still gonna develop in in
this last run i mean
i feel like the climax of the jimmy
mcgill story is
is kim right i mean whatever whatever
happens
it's pretty obvious that he's already
got everything in place to become saul
like he you know he he literally became
saul already
but he still has too much jimmy he still
has too much care for kim in him
so something that's gonna happen as as
he's on that slippery slope has to strip
those things away from him
and that becomes the end of jimmy
mcgill's story right and
so
where are you guys how are you guys
feeling about that after this setup here
it i mean do you
it's kind of a little on the nose if he
if if she just
gets a little bit too caught up in this
idea of howard right there i feel like
there has to be a little bit more
that's gonna come out here
yeah i mean the um mike storyline has
always felt like a separate and parallel
thing to the jimmy storyline and we know
that they work with each other
uh once you get to the time of breaking
bad so
i think those worlds are they have to
collide this season
in unexpected ways and i think one of
those unexpected ways is to what degree
will kim be involved in those worlds
colliding i mean of course we've seen
some of it when she stood up to lalo
last season
but going after howard is one thing but
what happens when she gets involved in
the goings-on of the cartel
so i don't know exactly what's going to
happen but i assume things are going to
get
dark they're going to get violent
and like you said it has to change jimmy
into pretty in some pretty substantial
ways he has to be able to deal with
violence and not get traumatized by it
he needs to get to a point where he can
suggest to walt hey maybe we send your
brother-in-law to belize
yeah
i mean
i can't wait to see where they go i mean
that's a i feel like a broken record
with it but i mean
my big takeaway from the first two
episodes were that
this is
a different this feels like it's moving
towards the end
definitely and as much as i'm invested
and as much as it's a prequel and i
already know where
so many so many of these characters
already end up like
i still
it's really hard to speculate on
how that's gonna play out
yeah i'm i'm
really excited even just logistically to
see how they intertwine with the
breaking bad timeline
it's it's uh
it's just it's such an interesting
question to see what exactly they're
going to do like imagine if we see kim
interacting with jesse or walt you know
some scene that took place that we
didn't know about in breaking bad you
know i i don't think that's likely
necessarily but unexpected things like
that
even just from a fanboy standpoint i'm
just excited to see how they pull it off
well yeah it's pretty fascinating
because i read an interview where they
asked why they decided to announce that
that jesse and and walt would be coming
back that brian cranston and aaron paul
would be appearing
and they you know they said that
it wasn't the biggest twist or the
biggest shock that's going to happen so
they thought it was all right to throw
that out there and
you know that that's that's pretty
exciting when you think about it
yeah it's i've always thought that they
had to show up because you can't just
gloss over breaking bad that was such an
important that's what turned uh saul
into gene it's a pretty
important event in his life
uh so
i mean i guess it's a twist that they're
coming back if you think of the show
from a meta standpoint like getting
these actors to come back it's it's an
impressive thing
but if somebody were writing a book you
know
you would 100 expect walt and jesse to
show up at some point
yeah
yeah i i you know i understand the idea
of you don't want there to be a cheap um
just bring them in
and you know just just to just to for
for fan service but
i think there's legitimate reasons why
they need to tie the two series together
like you mentioned um
i think it can be done in flash forwards
i don't think they need to show up in in
the jimmy mcgill timeline necessarily
you know yeah i mean i think we're still
a few years out from that so yeah we're
four years you know at the end of at the
end of the ppd it was four years between
the the that and um
the first episode of breaking bad
yeah so i think that would have to be a
flash forward i would guess flash
forward or i've been saying it for a
while a lot of people don't agree with
me but this show loves montages and we
did gloss over
i think six months back in season four
which is something stupid montage
so could we get through those four years
with some sort of a montage they get
into some kind of saul goodman kim's
helping him behind the scenes some kind
of status quo until something major
bulldozes into saul's life and ruins it
and that bulldozer is named walter white
yeah i i think um you know like i said i
understand why you know this is you know
people want them to handle it in a way
that isn't fan service-y and you know i
think that these guys obviously have
earned our you know earned or
they i think they understand the the
same concerns that that people have
they're not they're not you know
operating out of some kind of bubble and
i just think that it would be such a
huge thing you know i mean like you know
i talked about this on one of the
podcasts i was on uh with bald move like
it
you can you can say i don't want to see
fan service but seeing walter white is
is something that is a thrill you know i
mean it's something that
there's just something that's it's
amazing it's something that you've been
waiting to see and it's going to be fun
when it happens
right we we do all want to see fan
service but not in a distracting way
where it feels like you know one thing
the show does so well that some other
shows and stories don't do well
is it never forces characters to be
somewhere just for the sake of plot you
know for example they talked about how
much they would love to do an episode of
jimmy and mike having to for some reason
make a trek through the desert and it
took them
you know five or so years to get there
because they will always abide by the
characters they will always follow the
characters in a natural way and if it
takes all six years to become if it
takes jimmy six years to become saul
goodman it's gonna take six years so
these writers maybe more than any other
writers i've ever watched have
completely earned my trust
so um yes i do want fan service but only
from not in a contrived
way yeah exactly i trust peter gould
vince gilligan
tom schnauz and the other writers to
give us proper fan service
yeah i agree too i mean like i said um i
i i know that it's gonna bring the house
down and i'm i'm here for it i'm i'm
anxiously anticipating it i wonder if
it's going to happen in the first half
of the season
what do you guys think are the what do
you think the chances first half or
second half for the walt and jesse
appearance i think they're gonna milk it
i think they're gonna wait till the
second half yeah i mean first half would
be pretty shocking i mean if it was done
in a flash forward i guess they could
make that work
um but yeah i put my money on second
half just it's just too exciting to to
use in the first
seven episodes would you like to see a
scene from a different perspective i
know that's been an idea that's been out
there um
one thing that i could see them
maybe adding some context is the time in
ed's basement
with yeah walt and jimmy like i could
see that that being something that might
be worth um revisiting
yeah i
almost just from uh when you listen to
the insider podcast you can hear how
excited they get
just by like having to recreate gus's
trailer or having to recreate the hay
truck that transports you across the
border so i feel like it would almost be
too fun of a challenge for them to walk
away from to try and even maybe even
take footage from breaking bad but then
try to film new footage from a different
perspective and seamlessly integrate
them kind of back to the future 2 style
where marty goes back in time and you
see scenes from the first movie from a
different perspective
i i think i think from a pure
storytelling standpoint it makes sense
because all these events were very
important for jimmy mcgill saul goodman
uh and then just from like a geeky
filmmaking standpoint i feel like the
writers just wouldn't give up the chance
in a challenge to do that
yeah and i i think they did i think they
had to rebuild his office whenever they
did the the 405 flash forward that's
right that was quite a ride
i think that i remember that in the
insider podcast back then was that they
they were saying they had to rebuild the
whole thing you know from photographs
and you can hear they love doing it you
can hear the passion of course
can you imagine can you imagine going
into the office for the day and being
like hey you know what i had an idea can
we rebuild seoul's
you know an exact replica of uh
saul's office could we do that
yeah that's that's a day job i wouldn't
mind
yeah
we got another um
another question here
sorry my dogs are are freaking out in
the other room
is it considered a question if it ends
in four exclamation points
maybe it's not i didn't read it i just
i just clicked on it
better break north new series nacho
escapes to alaska hires jesse six years
later what would you guys think about if
they brought in a post a post el camino
scene
so uh i don't think it's impossible but
if it does i think if it was post el
camino it would purely be in the sense
that it literally in the timeline takes
place after el camino i doubt we'd see
jesse at that point el camino already
felt
oh i liked it but it already felt a
little gratuitous to me how dare you so
so to have even more jessie like post el
camino uh
unless i did something really
interesting i would have a bit of an eye
roll toward that one yeah i think it
would be hard to make that um
mean something you know what i mean like
the the
it's better not to know what happens to
him it's better to know that he had a
chance
and then fill in those blanks yourself
of what that might look like i think
then i like to imagine you built a cabin
yeah
when if we don't know he can do anything
you want you know right but he does love
to build that box he built an art class
yeah
it was a shop shop class or something
right right
yeah
so yeah that i i i would be
not i mean i wouldn't put it past them
being able to pull off a post um el
camino scene but i wouldn't be i
wouldn't be rooting for that if it was
if it came up in the uh you know in
possibilities
how are you guys doing on time i just um
we're gonna be able to hang out for a
little bit longer yeah sure just let me
know if we need to
to wrap it up um i was i didn't i don't
think we mentioned it i was thinking
around two hours but um i don't think we
mentioned before we jumped in so
i have a tendency that if people keep
asking questions that to just kind of
answer them and get lost and not really
think about what else is going on so
we have another one here from mod mary
thank you for the 499.
i think i've identified huel as the one
getting money from jimmy in the car same
shirt can you speculate on can you
speculate on what this might mean
um
do you guys want to talk about
teasers and and potential stuff
oh this is uh next time on
yeah okay i was saying like i do not
remember yeah
yeah we we usually don't watch those i
don't mind if you want to talk about it
but we usually don't watch the next time
on and try to remain as unsullied as
possible
all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna speak to this
vaguely i guess um
a bunch of people pointed this out in
the comments of my last video
which makes me believe that there's
probably something to it
um i i did look at the shirts i i don't
know that it's a hundred percent but
it's you know
it there's a resemblance but as far as
what it might mean
i mean we see that huel is doing
something there and
i i kind of think that what i said in
the in the in the actual video about
what he might be purchasing
i think those things might be connected
what um
what huels doing and
that little gadget that we see but um
other than that i don't know and these
guys don't
watch ahead and i know other people feel
that way too so i i wish i could give
you a better um answer but that's all i
really got well having not seen it just
based purely on what i'm hearing you say
my speculation is that hule has taken
some of jimmy's money
to buy a giant machine gun to mount in
the back of his trunk yeah
yeah uh
do we have a machine gun here do you
think
do we have the thing that that they're
gonna have to try to uh figure out how
to bring back into the story later i
mean i know that they i know in season
five they they talk about this all the
time about how that was i think that's
kim i was gonna say i think gene is the
machine gun because the idea is you
flash forward to something and then you
have to explain it oh right okay well in
that sense yeah gene is the machine gun
it's been
kind of lingering the entire series yeah
i would not put it past these writers to
have had the whole thing with the cab
driver recognized him last season i
would wouldn't put it past them to have
put that in season five not knowing
exactly how it was going to pay off in
season six
you know that could be a machine gun
scenario and for people unaware
basically what we're talking about is if
you remember in season five of breaking
bad we had a flash forward to a big
machine gun
in
walter white's trunk and apparently the
writers put that in not knowing how it
was going to pay
off and vince gilligan complains about
it like he he said that it was like
he kept kicking himself because he's
like why did we do that we might we have
to figure out a use for this thing but
it just nothing was working and it was
just bothering him for from writing the
whole season of like how they were going
to actually use this thing
and i think they
came up with a pretty good idea at the
end of the day
it did occur to me by the way that um if
i remember correctly
jimmy or saul is the one that introduces
walt and jesse
to the um uh the pest what do you call
them the exterminators
you know the uh you know i ride in all
of them yeah ira and uh jimmy worked
with ira to steal the um hummel figure
yeah
alpine shepherd or bavarian boy that's
right so we may see um possibly this
season jimmy meeting them or maybe
hearing about ira's new gig as an
exterminator
that's true that is um there's there's a
lot of possibility there's so much road
they could if they if they really decide
to dip into that timeline there's so
many different things that they could
actually so many directions they could
go
you know
i i guess we'll start to think about
we'll start to take some questions that
people have them down in the comments
and and we'll start to wrap things up um
like i said maybe we'll try to hit
about two hours here
um anything that you guys wanted to
bring up that we didn't touch on already
i just want to go on record and say the
uh
the saw monkeys are definitely evil you
know yeah you know lala's an evil evil
person
that's still bothering you yeah
if i ever run for uh office one day i
don't want you to say he defended
uh a serial killer yeah well you condemn
the salamanca
yeah
well you will you yeah you know when you
condemn lalo and
say that he is actually pure evil at
this point because it seemed like you
kind of got you kind of like the guy
[Laughter]
i mean but that's the joy that's that's
why lalo is so good is because you can't
help it kind of like the guy
yeah like when nacho was having drinks
with him in season five right before he
opened the gate
i was a little jealous of nacho i want
to have a drink with lalo
yeah i mean you know just work on the
car hang out you know talk about how to
talk to the boss when you go see the
cartel you know what i mean yeah
eat some great food like he's always
making food for people like you know
what i mean like there that has to be
something to try when we first met him
he was cooking right and he turned to
nachos you gotta try this you're gonna
die oh yeah
it's a special family recipe oh
salamanca recipe i see what you're doing
there
we got another uh
another spin-off idea
another spin-off idea here from dubs
house and thanks again for the five
dollars breaking boston bill burr
escapes nacho to boston and links up
with nachos six years later wicked bro
[Laughter]
i built burr i
i was surprised that i i i guess we're
i'm going to mention the teaser again
that that part that they were just
talking about with huel i was surprised
that that wasn't bill burr
i i wonder if we're going to get a
uh kooby
um
if kooby's schedule will make it
possible for him to come back he's one
of the main characters that really would
make sense to show up in saul's story
can you think of any other ones that
that that we might be
expecting to see in these next couple of
episodes
uh the only one that i was thinking of
that hadn't occurred to me before was
jack and the exterminator crew uh and of
course bill burr i thought about but you
mentioned that i mean it's some i don't
know if we'll see it in this series but
at some point that secretary that he has
well he's gonna show up we he she was
the one they hired temporarily
temporarily she's got to come back at
some point that's right
yeah francesca will definitely be able
to franchise yeah yeah she's she's she's
been there for a long time by the time
we see her and at the strip mall and
she's had it she's had over
goodman by that point um on the uh
breaking boston idea um that did remind
me of another show that vince gilligan
worked on which is getting a spin-off uh
x-files they're apparently doing an
animated spin-off called x-files
albuquerque
and it's going to be a kind of humorous
take on it
and at the same time that also reminded
me that they're doing some animated slip
and jimmy cartoons
uh on the amc website
so if you're going into the comedy route
anyway
x-files albuquerque i wouldn't mind uh
saul goodman showing up there as a
recurring character maybe
yeah that would be cool
i did see those uh the trailer for that
slip and jimmy thing it didn't really
didn't seem to grab the it didn't seem
to hit that same uh sweet spot that the
tv show did it it felt almost like it
was
geared toward towards kids i don't know
if you guys watch that or not
no no i i do want to check it out i'm
just really curious what that'll look
like what the animation style will be
and everything
um i mean i watched a bunch of the gus
uh poyo cermanos training videos did it
look like yeah similar to that
well this one's no this is more like
yeah this is more like this is more like
a combination
yeah this is more like uh a young jimmy
and with other characters maybe marco
was one of them so he's like really like
a little cartoon character
yeah and and it and it and it just
wasn't it didn't seem like it was geared
towards you know the it seemed kind of
like it was childlike in the way that
they were we're doing things so i i
don't really know what to expect from
that
i just got an are they
if you can and i'll watch it you know
you know that that's an interesting
question i'm guessing you guys probably
saw the american greed that they made on
april fool's day
the the thing cnbc put out about um
jimmy mcgill
no i didn't i remember hearing about
that i don't know if i watched it oh
it's fantastic that's something that you
should go and watch as soon as you get
done here it's like a it's like the
first it's basically like the real show
american greed like up to the first
commercial and it's all about jimmy oh
awesome that's that's cool like they
they talked to like you know bill and
they talked to um
the other ada i can't remember her name
uh erickson um
and they have the kettleman's show up
and stuff like that awesome oh yeah we
gotta check that out yeah it's really
good it's really really good that sort
of reminds me of the bit they did for
the emmys one year where they have uh
jessie show up at the office uh like the
at the show the office and and
jesse's like yo creed what's going on
here and crete's like oh it's okay guys
my methamphetamine is here
well i saw one where uh jesse finds
brian cranston still living in the rv
from breaking bad like he doesn't want
to let go of that character
i'm trying to look and see if i see any
questions i saw somebody ask um gas fee
here we go was the guy who stole the
tiny statue for jimmy the same guy that
ran the exterminator company in breaking
bad yeah we mentioned that we kind of
glossed over it earlier but yeah jimmy
worked with a man named ira who if you
recall ended up trapped under a desk for
a few hours that was awesome which was
yeah it was hilarious and yes that i
don't know if you ran the exterminator
company i don't know
but he was yeah i think it was his i
think he was the boss and then okay todd
and the others worked for him and yeah
that's how they decided
sorry go ahead
i was just saying that's how they
decided to take over and use that as you
know as a as a way to cook was because
saul had dealt with him for a few years
whenever they got in trouble for
you know stealing from their clients and
obviously we saw that that started in
um
episode four or season four
yeah
i love that in that scene when he's
hiding under the desk and the guy orders
the pizza he's like you gotta come help
me help me so like this guy's in for the
night
yeah
yeah that was a that was one of those
that's season four
you know
i remember watching that the first time
and that we didn't we haven't talked
about this yet um
we we did we talked about the first
three seasons on on the podcast but we
didn't we didn't we never got into four
and
that's where i think it really gets
interesting how you know
they did this thing with jimmy in the
beginning of season four where he
doesn't know how he feels he doesn't
know what's going on he doesn't know how
to react to the fact that this happened
and he has this ptsd
and you know that's all still under the
surface for where he's at right now you
know what i mean so i i i think that's
that's pretty interesting that you know
he he he never moved past
that
place he was in after um
chuck's death he just sort of got swept
up into being a friend of the cartel and
had a little bit more trauma like palate
on top of that
and now his wife who he loves more than
anything is pulling him through this you
know elaborate scam and he can't help
but get caught up in it you know it's
obviously enjoyable to
to think about that rather than
what he's experienced over the last
couple seasons of this show
i i do really wonder if we're going to
see some kind of
reckoning with the emotions that jimmy
never really confronted with chuck is
it's hard to imagine how that's going to
happen it could happen through howard
where he confronts jimmy in a very tense
moment and there is some kind of
conversation about it but i think
there's a guilt that jimmy has ever
really confronted as soon as he learns
that the insurance premiums going up are
what for what caused howard to force
chuck out of retirement which led to
lantern as soon as jimmy found that out
he immediately perked up got a big smile
and no longer seemed disturbed by his
brother's death like
a master class and bottling up your
emotions and just not dealing with guilt
um and i really wonder if we're going to
see some kind of uh reckoning jimmy just
dealing with those emotions at some
point
yeah i mean we saw them come out a
little bit in season five at the end of
507 when he does the lightning bolts
shoot from my fingertips but there was
no real consequence to that other than
he looked like a nut job you know what i
mean right
it feels like there's still a a price
that he that that he hasn't hasn't
exactly paid yet that's going to come do
like a bill that's going to come due
there um
did we we did mention the idea of who
might be following jimmy and kim at the
end of the episode right we or at least
we said
we briefly mentioned it but i don't know
if we did a lot of speculating on who
that might be yet
okay
we we did say that we thought it was not
uh lalo initially
and
we we had talked about that and
then i know i my feelings changed after
i watched the teaser
um
where are you at on that right now
yeah so i initially thought lalo and
then again i think i said this earlier
but on rewatch realize that this really
doesn't add up we specifically see lalo
decide not to cross the border so it
wouldn't make sense for him to be in
proximity to um jimmy and kim
the the theory i've seen floated a lot
is that howard possibly hired a pi to
follow them i do kind of like that
theory because like we talked this we
did talk a bunch about but i think it
makes total sense for howard to already
suspect some foul play
as soon as he sees those drugs in his
locker he's gonna think of the
prostitutes that showed up at his lunch
he's gonna think jimmy's up to something
and he's gonna think about the last time
he saw somebody go head to head with
jimmy chuck and chuck hired a pi to hang
around the house wait for jimmy to barge
in and destroy the tape so i could see
the dots getting connected in howard's
head
maybe it's even the same pi i could see
yeah
it could happen
oh sorry go ahead i was just gonna say i
was just
saying that that was the idea that
there's a shot where we see the three of
them but the the third character is kind
of out of focus and
if you want to see that as the guy that
that chuck um hired it's there you know
what i mean oh oh really okay okay so so
a lot of people have kind of
yeah a lot of people have kind of
already that's just
uh you know that's just the truth that's
been accepted but i'm not 100 sure but i
i am leaning towards that it makes a lot
of sense like you're pointing out it
could also be the detective uh trying to
find de guzman that's another
possibility i saw floated i think right
now my money's on howard p.i
but
yeah saul brought suspicion on himself
with his just first of all just by
representing the guzman and and the fact
that he was able to pay the bail is a
huge red flag alone
then there's also the slip up where he
uh where he's where he revealed lala's
name
so there's a lot of reasons for people
to have eyes on him
yeah and i think that that is um what
we're gonna see in the next episode
we're gonna see that it's not just from
one direction it's from from all
directions that um they're gonna have to
be
being careful like you know what i mean
um
like you mentioned it kind of came out a
little bit in season one where where we
saw that everyone involved in that
situation already had uh some history
with
with jimmy you know
cliff maine howard and yeah uh kevin
wachtel and you know that there's ripple
effects to those kinds of things that
that play out in a person's life and
um you know it's
he's also a friend of the cartel
which you know that
that's not something that doesn't come
with responsibility right
pete's speaking from experience yeah
let me tell you
yeah
i can't really talk about that but
it's not something that you just walk
away from let's leave it there
[Laughter]
speaking of gangsters we got another um
another super chat from dove's house
godfather 2 ending scene
chuck kim howard and jimmy in a
conference room celebrating somebody's
birthday before jimmy has his law degree
what do you make of that
well i think we we got a scene kind of
uh with a similar tone uh to the winner
season 4 episode 10 when we see the
flashback to essentially the best moment
between jimmy and chuck where they're on
stage singing together you still see
some of the dynamic where chuck takes
the mic and he still sees himself as
kind of the superior brother but it ends
with them lying on a bed together
singing so in terms of a quick scene of
people being happy together before
everything went wrong
we got we got some flash of that
in a in a little uh
in a little weird coincidence this
person venture sly has uh
vito corleone as their heavy
but um
what do you think about this he thinks
that he's looking
he's looking for the same guy that set
up tuko um this never really crossed my
mind do you guys have anything
did that does that sound
possible to you
well you know if
if lalo really digs into like police
reports and stuff or or
the past and and figures out first of
all what happened with tuko that he beat
the crap out of this old guy wait a
minute that's the same old guy i met at
the lab
that's a possibility but if this were
the case i feel like he would have
crossed the border yeah it's got to be
something that would have required him
to stay in mexico right
yeah i mean i'm not saying anything
about it because i read something that
peter gould said that it it that totally
goes in a different kind of direction
which you know you can't really say if
he's trying to lead you in that
direction or if he's just bringing it up
but
it kind of
it kind of
influenced the way i'm thinking about it
and you know i
i don't want to i don't want to
influence everybody else because if
they're not into reading about what
people are talking about or looking at
teasers and stuff like that and i don't
want to i don't want to what's with
these guys that are spoiling everything
you know it's funny if you see um before
they officially announced jesse and walt
coming back you see like a red carpet
interview with peter gould and vince
gilligan and they're asked the question
will we see jesse peter gould gives kind
of a vague answer and then vince
gilligan kind of smiles opens his mouth
to put the mic in front of his face he
hesitates take the mic away and then
he's like up so they put the mic back
and he goes let's just say it would be a
shame if they didn't show up right and
then peter gould goes well there you go
so to me it looks like he slipped up
it's kind of like when jimmy said lalo
and then they were like all right let's
just announce it you know yeah
yeah he actually there's a lot of
interviews that that air that came out
right after the first two episodes there
where peter gould um does get into a lot
of different things and and he kind of
prefaces it he kind of prefaces it by
saying that that he's not giving away
the big stuff which is
is
i bet like i said i was kind of in the
rabbit hole yesterday i was i was making
a video about the teaser and then just
sort of clearing up the idea of what was
going on with the the safe because a lot
of people were asking about that with
gus and mike and nacho
and um i kept finding more different
stuff that he was saying i was like wow
that totally changes my mind about this
thing or that thing you know
he's he's being pretty open about
talking about
some of the thought process they had
getting us into this season and stuff
that's interesting
one day i'm going to go back and listen
to all of those
yeah i mean i i always i've been
listening to the insider podcast for a
long time i you know we've mentioned
that um
they they always add some interesting
tidbits there
i feel like this year there's just a lot
of print stuff that he's doing too
they're they're promoting it in a way
that they they
you know they're they're they're
definitely doing it it some justice for
its final season
yeah there's a lot of hype definitely
yeah and i feel like the show the
audience for has grown a lot since it
first started because i i remember going
around like
you know i was always a huge breaking
bad fan and i had all these friends who
were too
and i'm like have you guys been watching
better call saul and they're just like
oh no i never got around to it and and
way more people that i know personally
are super excited about the show now
than it used to be
yeah i think that they i think that they
kind of lost some of their st i mean i
think that they've keep kept a pretty
pretty consistent
um you know pretty consistent numbers i
think people have always watched but it
never it never reached that
next level that that you know water
cooler level that the breaking bad was
you know like where just people you had
nothing else in common with you could
talk about
about breaking bad because everybody
watched it
you know um
i think that
i think that like a lot of the press
um they they didn't really cover
those middle seasons i think they kind
of lost interest um in some ways and and
i feel like after season five that was
re rekindled some
and now there's a lot more people
at least on that end that are talking
about it
so um we're gonna i guess wrap things up
here uh
i did want to bring up that idea of
wolves and sheep one last time i think
that i've been thinking about that a lot
i don't really have anything too
profound to say about it but i i do
think about
the whole you know nature and nurture
and and how jimmy became who he is and
how this last season is going to kind of
help him realize his final form as it
were at least before we get back to gene
and see how it all ends or whatever
and i think that this idea you know it
there's a lot of there's still a lot
about jimmy that we don't know
um i hope we get a little bit more of
that one of the things that i would like
to know a little bit more about is
his relationship with his father and
this idea that that um
that chuck had that he stole all this
money uh you know that was sort of what
gave chuck
that was sort of the thing that let
chuck dehumanize his brother a little
bit was that
he could never really trust him because
he knew what he did and he killed his
father basically so you know i i thought
that was something that popping up at
the end here
when he's watching
kim
move into a different position you know
take a different
a different turn than than what what you
know i thought that in season five they
whenever he sees the finger guns and
he's sitting there and he's kind of like
wait a minute there's something here
that i didn't notice all this time you
know what i mean
so i don't know if you guys have
anything that you want to that that
brings up for you or anything but i
think it's something that we need to
keep in the back of our mind going
forward
no no nothing to to add really besides
yeah i mean we have to keep it in mind
and
i'm just i'm so excited to see where
things go this season uh with kim
uh with how how do things go with kim
and how does that affect her
relationship with jimmy how does that
affect jimmy himself
when jimmy becomes saul goodman how much
of jimmy is still there how much of saul
is just an act you know is he buying all
those things in his house just to make
him feel good when he's gene takovic
where's his head at is he regretful does
he pine for the days of saul goodman
does he regret the days of saul goodman
and then where does he go from there
so
it's just amazing that there's so much
i'm curious about that purely exists on
the where are these characters heads at
level it's not breaking bad where i'm
wondering will jesse live will walt live
it's where is jimmy's head at where is
kim's head at what were these what will
these characters be
at the end of this series here's one
tiny little insight in the
the transition from saul goodman to gene
gene is no longer taking the hair pills
yeah i thought about that earlier
clearly he's uh gone bald he either
doesn't care or probably more likely
it's good disguise
yeah it would help it would help to not
look like saul goodman i guess
no matter how much you want to have a
full head of hair
yeah
it's another thing he lost
yeah among many
that's one of the things i loved about
the opening too was that you know it's
showing us all this opulence but it's
also being packed up and and taken away
and seized you know what i mean
everything but into that no value box
right right yeah like he he he saved all
this stuff he had a reason
that some things beyond you know that
were precious for beyond just like you
know whatever monetary gain he had out
of all the scamming and that whole
lifestyle
and it and it all gets it all gets
brushed away at the end he doesn't he
doesn't carry any of it into that
lifestyle he has one shoe box
in gene's uh
closet that he can hold on to there yeah
so um do you guys have anything else
that you want to i mean obviously you
can you can plug your your podcast here
and your youtube channel gail um
yeah no just uh say about the show yeah
i think um we'll definitely have more to
say as the season goes on i think at
this point i've gotten uh i'm just ready
for episode three i'm ready to see where
this goes next
uh
you can if you wanna hear adam and i
talk more about better call saul you can
look up sawcast on any podcast app you
can also watch the episodes at our
youtube channel one take we do uh we do
an episode
an instant take right after the show
airs so to to kind of give you that
feeling of like right after the show's
ending you can rave about all your
theories with us
uh and then we do a longer analysis
later in the week that's right tell them
about this all week all the good stuff
oh yeah so uh in the lead up to the new
season i was doing a new better call saw
video daily
so if you're uh craving more better call
salt content between now and episode
three if you go over to one take you'll
see uh a bunch of better call saul kind
of video essay style videos
yeah
yeah that's um
definitely worth checking out um
i'm trying to think uh
[Music]
do we
well we'll talk about this afterwards
but um
i would like to talk to you guys again
um
and and maybe get some other people
involved as we go on so
throw it out there that we might we
might be continuing this was sort of an
experiment this first one um you know we
we know each other we talked to each
other about the show
we wanted to
get into a little bit more uh we're glad
everybody showed up so we want to thank
you guys for that um
you know it seems like it was a pretty
good conversation and i i liked reading
what you guys were saying there in the
comments
so there's possibility that that we
might do some more of these down the
road um
uh dessert
anything else because we have this big
question here the one that's on
everyone's mind that i thought we could
we could go out on if if there's nothing
else
so uh i think i know the answer to this
so about price will he come back
so uh
i in breaking bad we had um gail kind of
a goofy character ended up getting
killed but he showed up one more time
because there was a video of him singing
karaoke
uh price there was also a video of him
sitting on pies
so i think i think price is going to
have to get killed and we think i will
never see him again a few episodes later
we're going to see that tape
he's going to be he's going to be
identified by who i don't know but
that tape is gonna that tape is the uh
chekhov's gun of
the real chekhov's gun check out some
cheeks
yeah a better call saul huh
yeah i could see that uh yeah i don't
know i i i
i hope that they
find
thoughtful ways to bring all of the
characters back if you want to know the
truth you know if they make sense for
the story please bring them because
one thing i got out of re-watching was
man there's so many good characters in
this universe yeah you just do it
seinfeld style where gene um you know
they find out who he is
he's placed under arrest they have a
whole um jury trial and so they have to
bring in character witnesses yeah so
they bring back anyone he's ever
interacted with skinny pete and badger
show up they have to testify and stand
together like as a unit
yeah we'll see
all right well um like again i guess
yeah let's let's let's close this out um
thanks again everyone who showed up
thanks for everyone who contributed
definitely for all the super chats um
that makes it you know definitely makes
it a little bit easier to
set aside a couple hours to work on this
and and
not do other things related to the
channel and it's so much fun
to talk about these things in a way that
we can't really do whenever we're just
you know editing down a 15 or 20 minute
video so
i'm super excited
see where this season goes
excited to talk about it more
and that's all i got do you guys got
anything else you want to say there
no i'll just say uh thank you to
everybody who joined uh these live
streams are the most fun when there's an
audience to interact with
uh and then pete thank you for uh
arranging this and uh you know when i
first started out youtubing a couple of
years ago your channel was one of the
channels i watched to learn from
and i never thought a couple years later
i would have the honor of being on a
live stream with you so thank you for
arranging this and this was a lot of fun
i would definitely like to do it again
yeah yeah and i was nice to meet you
adam this is our first interaction and i
thought you brought a lot of interesting
stuff to the conversation too and um
yeah i'm always i'm always down to talk
and uh you know you guys are are doing
good content that i think everyone
should check out
and i hope we can make some more you
know
yeah sure too thanks thanks for having
us
yep all right
thanks again guys